all right Eggman you want to get fast
let's get fast
video game adaptations used to be known
as a dud genre thanks to no small part
to Sonic the Hedgehog however they are
now hotter than ever one of the last
Blockbusters to release before the
covid-19 pandemic struck in 2020 the
first Sonic film took in 319 million
dollars at the global box office its
sequel performed even better Sonic the
Hedgehog 2 introduced the villain
Knuckles voiced by Idris Elba who is due
for his own spin-off TV series on
Paramount plus and the movie franchise
isn't slowing down anytime soon as they
Sonic the Hedgehog 3 will drop in 2024.
not much is known about this next entry
in the series right now however a tease
on Twitter announcing the film back in
August 2022 suggests that both Tails and
Knuckles could be back in Action
alongside the eponymous Sonic once again
voiced by Ben Schwartz either way Sonic
is speeding towards release on December
20th 2024.